Oh,
have you seen that photo or the footage rather of the Jaguar that they found in
a Arizona?
Yeah.
That's really interesting too.
Right?
They're starting to make their way up from Mexico.
It's such a weird region that because here's this huge Sonoran desert that you
think none of these tropical animals can make it across.
And for whatever reason,
southern Arizona gets Jaguars and Coda Monday and peccary and all these like
tropical animals.
What,
what the hell?
I don't know the answer.
What the Hell's going on?
That all these rain forest creatures are making it through this thousand mile
stretch of desert and into southern Arizona?
Probably Board.
It could be for cool,
cool places to visit.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe they,
I mean maybe it's just like a natural instinct to Rome and expand your
territory.
There is,
look at that thing that's an incredible animal.
So beautiful.
And it's huge.
Huge there.
There are 200 plus pounds,
right?
So I'm a big fucking aggressive Kat.
What's bigger?
A Jaguar or a leopard?
Leopard.
Yeah.
And that's even bigger.
But it's such a beautiful animal to,
and apparently they were all over North America Jaguar point in time.
Yeah.
Like that area,
like Texas during the rezoning.
Oh,
interesting.
I didn't even know that.
But,
um,
when did they,
I mean they,
they were pushed out of,
I feel like that might not be true though.
I feel like there were,
they were more numerous in like Arizona and the southwest makes sense.
I mean,
you know,
we had so much mega fauna here back in the day,
um,
there would have been a lot of pray for them now because of the fact that he
spent so much time in the wild and you know,
and that you have this interest in these,
uh,
what would you call cryptozoology animals?
I'm not a crypto guy,
so just to be clear and nothing against crypto guys,
but I don't do lock Nasser big foot or anything and I'm a true wildlife
biologist,
so I only focus on wildlife.
So not to interrupt you,
but I'm just very,
very structured in the sense that I really only look for animals that we,
we have an understanding of.
Yeah.
Right.
Well.
Yeah,
well the big foot one is,
um,
the,
the most compelling but also probably the most bullshit.
I think there's a mix there.
I think people believe that they've seen certain things.
Um,
you know,
it's,
do I think that there could have been large primates that we attribute to
bigfoot?
Sure.
Whether they're still here or not,
whether people have ever seen him.
I,
I'm so like not well read on that.
Isn't it interesting though that if there was one it would probably be the most
spectacular find ever.
Absolutely.
Mima we have chimps and Bonobos,
you know,
we have all these things that are real well cause there's so much like Laura and
culture associated with it.
Right.
And not just like our Western culture,
but like k
things of big hairy creatures and like everything.
I mean it would be like this mind blowing discovery.
Have you ever went and looked for the Bondo ape?
No.
I know what it is,
but no,
never gone and looked for it.
I'm sure that's a real thing.
Really.
Yeah.
They've got skulls and hair samples and photographs and video,
and for people don't know what we're talking about.
It's a gigantic chimpanzee,
right?
Like a six foot tall chimpanzee,
which is just fucking nuts.
And it does walk a rack,
right?
Yeah.
Sometimes.
There's a camera trap photo.
There's a guy named Doctor Carl.
Oh no,
he's not a doctor.
I think his name is Karl Harmon.
Call Carl something at Harman.
Is that Ahmad?
Ahmad.
And he's a,
it was it Swiss wildlife photographer.
Anyway,
he set up a bunch of camera traps and he got one of 'em one walking.
I mean,
it's freaking,
there's some photos of,
um,
these gentlemen that shot one,
uh,
near an airstrip and it's fucking huge.
You don't know how big the the men are.
They might be small and it's in front of them,
but it is without a doubt,
like one of the biggest chimpanzees you've ever seen in life.
They have a crest on their head.
Their skull has a crest.
Like a gorilla.
Yeah.
It has like the bone of the skull has kind of just picture of that.
I'd love to see it.
I'm not not familiar with the anatomy of them.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's really interesting because I think for the longest time they didn't think
they were real as a part of that Michael Crighton Book Congo,
because remember there was a really terrible movie,
but with the size of that Fucker,
that's insane.
Yeah.
That's one of them.
And that thing that doesn't look like forced perspective,
you know what I mean?
It looks like they're right in front of them.
And that's one from the early 19 hundreds,
I believe,
where these guys a shot one.
And um,
there were like,
what is this?
This is just giant chimp goat.
See if you find the one of the red above is the one where it's walking right
there.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's the camera trap.
Wow.
Walking and he's erect.
Yeah,
he's erect.
And he's,
you know,
Izzy,
these people that,
one of,
one of the sightings,
they saw one walked by a truck,
like walk across the road,
they said it was the same height as the truck.
That's insane.
So they have like,
you know,
like a Toyota Helix or something like that.
And it's literally the size,
the height,
like a six foot tall man,
but a giant chimp.
And I mean,
you know,
to go back to the big foot thing,
you can totally see where we get that from.
Right?
For sure.
You look at this huge primate that's the size of a human being and your brain
instantly goes,
it's mythological.
And I'm pretty sure that they didn't have photos of this thing until the 20th
century,
like the late 20th century.
No kidding.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
It's a trip,
man.
This,
they nest on the ground like I'm like,
yeah.
Wow.
And uh,
the locals have two different name for,
uh,
two different names for chimps.
They called him tree beaters and lion killers and the tree beaters are the ones
that are up in the trees,
a smaller champs.
The lion killers are these big ones that live on the ground.
I had apparently there's some either video footage or there was some eyewitness
account of one of them eating a leopard.
No Way.
So it was a dead leopard that they were eating.
Whether or not they killed it or they found it,
but they were eating this fucking thing regardless like to be a primate at the
top of the food chain,
eating a big cat.
I mean,
that's nuts.
It's nuts.
Would you ever think of going there and trying to find those things?
They're deep in their great,
yeah.
I think they're in a place called ble,
ble in the Congo.
That's where they think they are.
They've isolated the population of them.
They're really,
my mom just got back from the Congo and she still does like her own adventure
stuff,
and she was saying it's just like she's been all over as well.
She's like,
it's mind blowing,
like there's so much remoteness and unstudied area that there could be all kinds
of things.
God Damn Man.